[Music]
hey everyone before we start this video
i just wanted to mention that only 20
of you are subscribed so if you enjoy
the content please consider subscribing
to support the channel
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory in this video we're going
to be discussing beloved
hogwarts headmaster albus dumbledore
diving deep into the question
did he ever kill anyone now the
dumbledore that we come to know and love
in the books and films is a calm
cool gentle and most of all calculated
man he has more wisdom than he knows
what to do with
and he is widely considered to be the
most powerful wizard of all time
it seems like he's got it all figured
out and he gives us the impression that
he has
always had it figured out but if we call
back just a little bit into albus
dumbledore's past
we can quickly find out that things were
not always so peachy keen for helpless
dumbledore
like everyone else albus 2 had to find
his way in the world
and to ultimately achieve what he did he
made a few mistakes along the way
at the end of the day he is only human
just like the rest of us
albus dumbledore was born in late august
1881 in a town called mould on the wald
a mainly wizarding town in the uk
in the autumn of 1892 at the age of 11
albus began attending hogwarts
when he first started attending hogwarts
he had a bit of a hard time
this stemmed from stigma surrounding his
father percival
who was sent to azkaban for attacking
three muggle children
percival's actions were in response to
muggle children in his hometown
attacking his daughter and albus's
sister ariana
people were under the impression that
the dumbledore family hated muggles
albus included and this made his
formative year at hogwarts difficult
despite hardships in his family during
his time at school
he excelled as a student which is no
surprise given that he is perhaps the
most innately talented wizard
of all time albus went on to win the
barnabas finkley prize for exceptional
spell casting
an award presented for showcasing
excellent spellcasting techniques
he also went on to win other wizarding
accolades such as a gold medal for
groundbreaking contributions
to the international alchemical
conference albus was as exemplary a
student as one could be
and was clearly a shining pupil with
remarkable capabilities and an uncanny
ability to learn
after finishing school in the year 1899
alberts returned to his hometown of
godric's hollow
to be with his family after the death of
his mother kendra dumbledore
albus being the eldest sibling knew that
he would have to take care of his
younger siblings
particularly ariana who had problems
controlling her magical abilities
it was during this time that albus
became friends with gelec grindelwald
a young man who had moved to his small
village to live with his aunt
matilda bagshot who was a family friend
of the dumbledores and grindelwald's
great aunt
immediately recognizing each other's
magical prowess and amazing magical
capabilities
the two boys hit it off immediately
despite being very close
the pair eventually hit a crossroads
they hit a point where their paths would
diverge in a very big way
it was grindelwald's intention to find
the deathly hallows
then lead a wizarding revolution that
would effectively put an end to the
international statute of secrecy
breaking down the secretive divide
between the two worlds
muggle and magical this revolution would
create a global power hierarchy
that would place powerful witches and
wizards at the top of the food chain
effectively giving them full control of
muggles and muggle affairs
what may surprise you most about this
plan is that dumbledore was fully on
board with it
what we see grindelwald trying to
accomplish in fantastic beasts
as the antagonist is something that our
very own beloved
hogwarts headmaster almost contributed
towards
it's hard to believe the gentle kind old
man that looks after the hogwarts
student body
once wanted control over muggles it
seems so out of character
and it's really a huge blemish on
dumbledore's record yes
he was young stupid impressionable and
muggles had indirectly torn his family
apart
but still having wizard kind rule of a
muggle kind
seems a bit extreme the only reason that
grindelwald and dumbledore eventually
parted ways
was because grindelwald used the
cruciatus curse on dumbledore's brother
aberforth aberforth openly express has
disgust
their plan and grindelwald did not
handle the situation
very well though dumbledore was very
close with grindelwald
he was always going to protect his
brother when the cruciatus curse was
placed on aberforth by grindelwald
a jewel broke out between the three
wizards albus's sister ariana got caught
in the crossfire
and was killed this effectively put an
end to the relationship
between dumbledore and grindelwald and
meant that dumbledore would have no role
in grindelwald's plan
to establish a global wizarding
hierarchy so even if dumbledore never
went through with the plan
there was clearly a time in his life
where he made some morally dubious
decisions
he wasn't the man that we know today i
can't help but wonder what sorts of
things he did
while he was in this morally transient
state but i also wonder
if he was willing to make these more
questionable decisions in his youth
if any of it followed him into adulthood
was dumbledore more of a morally dubious
person than me might care to believe
dumbledore is known to be the only
person that voldemort ever feared
even the death eaters feared him and
their whole thing is that they are pure
evil
and don't fear anything interesting that
they would fear a wise old wizard
regardless of how powerful he is if he
is just pure in the greatest sense of
the word
surely dumbledore must have an edge
though this edge isn't exposed to us
directly
there is a clue in the deathly hallows
which suggests that dumbledore may even
be capable
of murder of course you were said harry
of course
how can you ask that you never killed if
you could avoid it
true true said dumbledore and he was
like a child
seeking reassurance in this passage with
the utterance of just two words
dumbledore effectively exposes an
entirely new side of himself to the
reader
and he was like a child seeking
reassurance it's just a slightly less
direct way of saying
yes domidor killed before i would
imagine the dumbledore had killed
but only when the circumstances demanded
it if he had truly never killed then he
would have given harry a much more
direct response
something like yes i would never kill
someone or
i have never killed at all there are
also a few other
less direct segments from the books and
films that suggest dumbledore is capable
of killing
when harry looked into the pensive in
the last movie to see snape's vision
we see snape saying don't kill me to
dumbledore
why would snape ever say don't kill me
to someone like dumbledore
if he truly didn't believe that domino
was capable of killing
snape attended hogwarts while dumbledore
was there so surely he would have known
the type of person
the dumbledore was snape is a highly
intelligent man
and what this tells me is that he was
privy to dumbledore's darker side
he knew that he had wronged dumbledore
the potters and the order of the phoenix
by working as a death eater
and he pleaded with dumbledore to spare
his life because he genuinely feared for
it
he genuinely thought the dumbledore was
capable of killing him
at this point in time snape was of
course a death eater
and as we know the death eaters fear
dumbledore
i can think of one reason that they'd
fear him beyond the possibility of being
captured
that reason is that they feared that
they would be killed by him
war is a dirty business and dumbledore
was the leader of the order of the
phoenix
the main opposition of the death eaters
in war there are always casualties
and amidal is no fool he must have
understood that sometimes
killing was necessary the only way that
i would be able to read this differently
is if snape just forgot human decency
altogether perhaps after hanging around
the death eaters for such a long time
he forgot how decent people can behave
not expecting someone like dumbledore
to spare his life had a member of the
order of the phoenix come face to face
with voldemort
they surely would have been met with the
killing curse so
that's my argument for why dumbledore
likely killed but there are some
counter-arguments for why he possibly
never stooped quite so low
the following passage from the order of
the phoenix shows an exchange between
dumbledore and voldemort
which indicates that dumbledore doesn't
need to kill as he believes that there
are fates
much worse than death you do not seek to
kill me
dumbledore called voldemort his scarlet
eyes narrowed over the top of the shield
above such brutality are you we both
know there are other ways of destroying
a man tom dumbledore said calmly
continuing to walk towards voldemort as
though he had not a fear in the world
as though nothing had happened to
interrupt his stroll up the hall
merely taking your life would not
satisfy me i admit
there is nothing worse than death
dumbledore snarled voldemort
you are quite wrong said dumbledore
despite dumbledore admitting here that
he doesn't want to kill voldemort
it still comes across as quite sinister
he walks towards voldemort with such
confidence
and calmly explains that simply killing
voldemort would not completely satisfy
him
this makes the counter argument somewhat
less effective because even though he's
expressing that he doesn't want to kill
voldemort
it almost sounds as if he's suggesting
something even more sinister
which would make him capable of killing
in my eyes the main argument for
dumbledore not being a killer is the
fact that grindelwald's life was spared
after dumbledore defeated him
grindelwald was immensely powerful
so the train of thought here is that if
dumbledore could defeat someone as
powerful as grindelwald
without killing him then he wouldn't
ever really need
to kill anyone my issue with this is
that dumbledore had a very complex
relationship
with grindelwald and probably still had
feelings for him at the time of his
defeat
i don't think that dumbledore really
wanted him dead he was fine with him
just being imprisoned in nurmengard
dumbledore has no personal attachment to
death eaters
so in my eyes i think that he would be
far more inclined to kill them
particularly if they put the lives of
those that he loved or cared for
in danger i don't think that he ever
killed if he could avoid it
and the following passage from the order
of the phoenix shows us one way that
dumbledore dealt with death eaters
if you proceed downstairs the department
of mysteries cornelius
said dumbledore you will find several
escaped death eaters
contained in the death chamber bound by
an anti-disapparition jinx
and awaiting your decision as to what to
do with them however
that doesn't mean that he didn't kill
them in the past or that he wouldn't be
capable of killing them
ever again death eaters don't seem to
fear imprisonment
but they definitely fear dumbledore what
do you guys think
do you think that dumbledore ever killed
was he capable of it
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time
you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you